All right.
Welcome, everybody.
We're so happy to have you
here, breakout session number 2.
My name is Tamara Brenner.
I'm executive director
at the Derek Bok Center
for Teaching and Learning.
And we are welcoming
you to our session
on improving learning by
studying student learning.
And I love the
layout of this room,
because it makes it really easy
for you to talk to each other.
And we're going to be doing
a fair amount of that.
And so what I want you
to do is actually start
by talking to a partner.
Why are you here,
meaning specifically,
why did you choose to come
to this session instead
of any of the other
three sessions right now?
Why are you interested in
spending some time thinking
about studying student learning?
So you've got
about four minutes.
Talk to some people
at your table.
All right.
So I'm going to bring you back.
So hopefully everybody now has
met somebody at their table.
I forgot to tell you to
introduce yourselves,
but hopefully you all
took care of that,
and you've got some idea
of who you're talking with.
So when we're teaching,
we are getting
a sense of how our
students are learning
through various
types of assessments
we might be giving them--
writing papers, tests.
And yet, it's quite
likely that you still
have a lot of questions about
your students' learning.
What are they getting?
What are they
having trouble with?
What kinds of
misconceptions do they have?
How are they
approaching learning?
So there's always questions
about student learning.
One approach to looking
at how students learn
and student learning
in our classrooms
is called the scholarship
of teaching and learning,
which is often
referred to as SOTL.
And this is really thinking
about a systematic inquiry
of student learning
in your own classroom.
And so that's
important, is that this
doesn't have to be done
by some outside expert,
but that you as a
practitioner can actually
be studying student learning.
And a way to think about it
is that, if you are a faculty
member and you're doing
research, scholarly research,
in your own field, you're
going to be thinking
about problems and questions.
And you're going to
be thinking about ways
of collecting evidence, and ways
of interpreting that evidence.
And you can do the same kind
of thing in your classroom.
You can be asking questions
about student learning
and about teaching.
You can be collecting evidence
about student learning.
And the goal here
is really to improve
the quality of education.
So as the title
is, we're learning
about student learning for
the sake of improving student
learning.
So what we're going to be
doing in the session today is,
we have two speakers who
are going to talk about some
of their own experiences
with collecting information
and evidence about
student learning.
So we have two case studies.
And after that we'll be doing
some individual and group
work, thinking about how we
might do some of these things
on our own.
How might we ask
our own questions
and start collecting
some data ourselves?
So I'm pleased to introduce our
first speaker, Henrike Besche.
She received her
PhD in Biochemistry
in Germany in 2004,
and since then she
has been here at Harvard
Medical School in Cell Biology,
first as a postdoctoral
fellow and then
as a curriculum fellow.
When she was a
curriculum fellow,
she became involved with medical
education and the Pathways
curriculum, which is a flipped
discussion-based curriculum
launched at the
med school in 2015.
She is now working
as associate director
of curriculum integration.
She's teaching for three
months of the year,
and the rest of the
time she's focused
on improving basic
science curriculum
across the entire four
years of the MD program.
I'm going to turn
it over to her now.
Thanks, Tamara.
I'm actually teaching right
now, so this is my retreat
for like a day.
But where's the slide advancer?
So I'm going to give
you one example.
I really love using
data to figure out
how our teaching is
going, and today there's
one story I wanted
to share with you.
So just to briefly
give you some context,
we're going to
focus on teamwork,
but I thought it wouldn't make
much sense unless I introduced
to you a little bit about
what we're currently
doing at the medical school.
So not very long ago,
teaching at our school
simply pretty much
looked like this picture
from the 1940s in
Albany Medical School,
so lectures, lectures,
and more lectures.
And if you went into a
lecture hall recently,
you would look down, people
were on their screens.
At least a third of the
students doing other things,
and the other
two-thirds were at home
sleeping, because they could
watch that thing online later.
So we realized
there really wasn't
much of an intellectual
exchange going
on that would justify
to actually bring
students and faculty together.
So we decided to just
not do that anymore.
But what do you do instead?
So instead, now we have a
discussion-based curriculum
in these classrooms.
It's actually a picture
from our classroom.
You can see students
sitting at these tables.
You have, on this
image, actually
three faculty
members in the room
engaging with those students.
So we adopt this pedagogy, CBCL,
or case-based collaborative
learning.
And it started in 2015.
So I just wanted to
dissect what that
means for you a
little more before I
dive into the teamwork.
So "flipped" means
students study
before they come to class.
Class is now mandatory for them.
And it's case-based
in the sense that,
throughout their first
year of medical school,
it becomes increasingly
actually based on patient cases.
But you could also extrapolate
and frame it as problem-based.
So we typically give
them application problems
that stretch and deepen the
kind of content they were
exposed to in the prep work.
And it's collaborative.
Students are working
in tables of four.
So these tables of
four are the teams
I'm going to refer to
throughout the presentation.
And then it's discussion-based.
So this discussion goes
through an alternating rhythm
of talking with their team,
talking amongst peers,
back to discussing with the
larger group with a faculty
member.
So we did this.
We pretty much pulled
the rug out on lectures.
And as you can imagine,
implementation wasn't smooth.
Overall, successful,
but we definitely
had an intense phase of
learning from our students,
what was working and
what wasn't working.
And initially when we flipped,
workload was a gigantic story.
I mean, all these expert
faculty front-loading
all their expert
knowledge was pretty much
leading to prep times that were
absolutely not sustainable.
Case-based, it's actually
not easy to decide what makes
a good classroom discussion.
Things was yes or no
answers are pretty dead
the moment you ask them.
So there was a lot of
work that went into that.
Not soon into the curriculum,
about a year in, I
started to hear
a lot of students
on the side talking about mixed
experiences in their team.
So that's what got started what
I'm going to present today.
And then one big
piece of focus right
now is actually facilitation.
So we have recently launched
a peer-coaching program
to have faculty actually become
even better facilitators.
So I could talk to any of those.
If anyone's interested, please
let me know after the session.
But today I'm going to focus
on the teamwork, with a focus
on, how do we get the data
to actually figure out
what's going on?
So again, this is
the CBCL classroom.
And I need you to understand
this scheme, which
is the CBCL classroom, of
which we have four running
at the same time with
around 44 or 43 students
sitting at 11 tables of four.
So every green square
is one of these tables
with four students.
Typically one or three faculty.
It really depends on the course
or the kind of session you run.
And again, times four.
So when we started out, faculty
envisioned, this is what it is.
Everyone's green,
content, happy, satisfied,
has a great experience.
In fact, we haven't given
the team part any thought.
Faculty were totally
focused on content delivery.
Teams, they just
happened to work.
And anecdotally, I learned
that might not be the case.
So in conversations
with students,
I realized some students
had a terrible experience
occasionally.
They really were sitting
with people they really
didn't get along with, and then
they were just sitting it out.
Or they had a so-so experience.
They all had great tables.
Don't get me wrong.
But they all had
terrible tables, too.
But the more I talked
to people, the less
I could put a finger on,
well, is this a problem?
How big is the problem?
Am I making the problem up?
And I certainly didn't
want to make a problem up,
and to start bothering faculty.
Was this a problem
if it was really
like 5% of the students
occasionally having a problem?
So the question was,
how do we measure this?
So I looked in the
literature and found
a nice, 17-item, team-based
performance scale that I just
ran through the class.
I asked the professor
to collaborate with me,
and we made it a assignment
in one of the courses
to fill out that survey with
a qualitative piece to it.
So there wasn't just
this scale that I
could turn into a
number, there was also
the question of what's working
in the team you're currently
working with and what
could be improved.
So I took those data and
was able to piece together
what I roughly consider
a representative image
of a typical CBCL classroom,
with orange indicating
significantly lesser
of a good experience
than the others
sitting at your table.
So I'm looking for
a gap in experience.
I can't fully judge
it, but there's a gap.
There was a gap in how
these individuals rated
that experience.
The orange squares
signify people
that had a lower-performing
team experience.
And you'd find these asymmetric
tables with one person
kind of feeling isolated in
the experience, and just said,
this isn't working for me,
but the other three people
had a reasonably good time.
You'll see the split
tables with a couple
of people feeling great, and
the other too often feeling
excluded.
And then occasionally you'd
see this big orange blob,
which is what I call a toxic
table, with cognitive biases,
emotions running really high,
like really bad stuff happening
that didn't seem
conducive to learning.
So that's where we arrived.
But then I was really
happy I made the decision
to not just ask about those
quantifiable questions,
but also ask what was working
and what was not working.
Because what I needed
to know, what would it
take to make this better?
So this is what I learned
from reading those comments.
So I did a pretty brief,
qualitative type of analysis,
and three big domains
stuck out to me.
It was emotions.
How did you feel in that team?
It was whether or not that team
had a way of working together
to kind of process, and how they
actually talked to each other,
how they communicated.
And so in a good team, in a
good classroom experience,
they felt safe and valued.
Often they would
actually have a process
to go around and elicit
everyone's opinion explicitly.
So they were not just
haphazardly talking
at each other.
They were systematic about it.
Another big thing is
respecting that everybody
thinks at a different pace.
So they were actually adamant
about giving each other
that space to think quietly
before starting to talk,
or they would use
different methods.
They wouldn't just talk, but
they would draw things out
on boards and such.
And that kind of
process also seemed
to help with valuing
everyone's opinion.
So it's not like they asked
everyone to say something.
They also valued and truly
listened, didn't interrupt,
and in that process we're able
to emphasize the reasoning
and push for deeper thinking.
So the orange people described
a very different experience.
So often that orange color
is associated with feeling
outright dismissed and unsafe.
They complained about
side conversations that
make them feel excluded,
they complained
about a lack of process.
So it was just pure chaos
unfolding at these tables,
too much focus on
the correct answer.
And med students have this
famous expression of the gaana
mentality, so that
seemed to come out
in some people at these tables.
Answers blurted out without any
consideration of where others
were in the thinking process;
lack of discourse reasoning;
and just not being heard;
some person dominating
at these tables were
common complaints.
So maybe that's not
surprising, right?
We've all had
experiences of co-workers
that we just can't
stand, and meetings that,
if we have to sit with that
person, it's just a nightmare.
That's fine.
People will be people.
But I did want to know, is there
something we can do about it?
Because I strongly felt
that, well, maybe we just
need to tell them
how to work together.
Maybe they need to know
that you need a process.
Maybe that's a thing, and if
we tell them, it gets better.
So we're telling them that now.
That's not the
question I tested.
We're giving them
the information
that I just showed you, and
feed them forward right now.
But at that time,
I just said, OK,
why don't we give them
some time to just talk
about how it's going, how
they want to work together?
So we gave them the time.
I found another course
to collaborate with,
and they got 20 minutes to,
at the beginning of their team
work, to talk to each other,
how they want to work together,
and another 20 minutes
a week or so later
to talk about how it was
going and make adjustments.
And that simple act
of giving them time
led from what we had
looked at here, which
was the end status of teams
after four weeks of the course
without any consideration
to the team process,
it turned into this.
So just to make
sure you understand,
these are different teams.
It's not a controlled
experiment.
But with those additional
two times, 20 minutes,
they were able to
overall come out
just simply looking like they
were getting along better.
And I'm not showing
that here, but it's
not just that we prevent toxic
teams potentially by this,
but the OK-functioning
teams actually
became high-functioning
teams, as well.
So also, the green
isn't just green.
There are shades of green, data
that I'm not presenting here.
So I'm calling this
my intervention group,
but in an experimental
design kind of sense,
there is no control here.
So to translate that back
to what we're doing at HMS,
there's more that
went into this,
but it led me to
conclude that what
we can do for our CBCL
classrooms is maybe formally
create times for teams
to set norms and give
each other feedback
as just standard part
of the curriculum.
Now I want to pilot
peer feedback.
Maybe that's something
we can fold into this
and further enhance
communication,
interpersonal skill
building, which is something
that I'd be excited to do.
But we'd also give them maybe a
more, bigger context for that.
Give them a little
more knowledge
about where this
is all coming from.
So if you thought this is
interesting, that's great.
I do, too, and I
love this project.
But that's actually not
what I wanted to talk about
with you in a sense.
What I hope you would realize
is that this is actually
an example of how
you can use the mind
frame of continuous
quality improvement
to drive what you
do in the classroom.
So I've been a scientist for the
better part of my adult life,
and I miss the scientists,
and I'm very data driven.
But I've always been hindered
by hypothesis-driven research,
because it ends you
in a position where
you have to have this control
group, and it's very limiting.
And doing educational
research in a way
that you have that
perfect control group
and you have that
hypothesis, it often just
doesn't fit into real life.
And you can't withhold
entire pieces of instruction
from half of the class,
and then give it to others,
and then test them
on the same thing.
So what I hope you
can acknowledge
is that, in this
scenario, we move
from a curriculum with
lectures and no consideration
of teamwork, to
something where we
had active learning
and some teams,
but no framework, to
collaboration and teamwork
is actually a program objective
of the medical degree, which
I found out later.
So it fits nicely.
It gives me a lot of leverage.
So I now aim to make
active skill-building
and peer feedback
really be an integrated
part of the curriculum, and
who knows where that leads me.
So this is the framework of
continuous quality improvement.
You're driving change.
You're driving that boulder
up the hill, telling people,
peer feedback is a great thing.
Three years ago
every medical student
was running away from me if I
mentioned that in the hallway.
And faculty were dismissing
me, saying, oh gosh,
who wants to deal with that?
That's going to be
a social nightmare.
So you're not only learning
what your students might need,
you're also educating students
and faculty at the same time.
So there's a dualism.
So just to compare
this to research,
so QI is not
hypothesis-driven, it's
just about how this is going,
how we can make it better.
And it frees you have
these limitations
that often research brings in
terms of experimental design.
You can do it in a more
incremental fashion
that, I drive this in a
kind of yearly rhythm.
I figure out, what
next piece can I
work out in the next six
or eight or nine months?
While research, I think,
has a lot of benefit,
but I've found this
framework really liberating.
So this wouldn't be
possible without some
of the people in the room.
There's the Office of
Educational Quality Improvement
that was just founded at
HMS, which was Amy Sullivan,
Barbara Cockrill, John
Dalrymple, Carolyn over there,
and Steve ran that office and
have helped me out with this.
And then Ed Hundert
is our dean, who's
really a champion for
data-driven improvement
of teaching, and Randall King
is my long term collaborator.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
All right.
So we have time for
one or two questions.
Any questions for Henrike?
I'm just wondering
how you got buy-in.
Because that seems like
a very dramatic change.
Oh, when we changed
the curriculum?
I wasn't at the very
initial meetings.
I was part of a
committee that created
one of the latter courses
in the curriculum.
And I think there was an
executive decision being
made at a higher
level that we're
going to go through with this.
And at the time I thought,
this is never going to work.
They didn't give us
any instructions.
Because they said, we're
going to go flipped,
do something
discussion-based, but there
wasn't like, do this kind.
There was no information
how we were to do this.
In retrospect, I thought
it was ingenious,
because when the
faculty got together
to get concretely going,
to say, how are we
going to change our course?
There was a lot of
deliberation in the room,
but we still had the freedom to
make it our own in the process.
And there was a lot of whining
about letting go, and fear.
But overall, I think some
form of demanding change,
but then giving people
creative freedom, made it work.
But as I said, I
wasn't at those,
when that decision was
made to really go ahead,
I wasn't there for that.
All right.
One more question.
How were the original
groups formed?
Oh yeah, we just
assigned them, and then
we rotate them and permutate
them throughout the year.
Did you ever consider
not doing that and--
I would go as far
as considering that,
but I think that is too
early in this process.
I think we should
have longer teams,
and give them more support
to emotionally grow
in those teams.
Right now, I think the most
I can ask is for four months.
And I'm making inroads
on longer teams.
But I know of one team-based
curriculum at the School of--
its Charlestown, Institute
of Health Professions.
They have a 14-month
TBL curriculum,
and they lock those
in on day one.
And then they have
a mediator to help
the teams that run
into conflict they
can't resolve on their own.
All right.
Thank you very much, Henrike.
Next up we have David Levari.
He finished his PhD
in Psychology in 2018
here at Harvard.
He was working with
Daniel Gilbert.
He is now a post-doctoral
research associate
at Harvard Business
School, working primarily
with Michael Norton.
While he was a PhD
student here at Harvard,
he also worked with the
Bok Center for Teaching
and Learning as a
department teaching fellow,
and he worked with us as a
co-author on our relatively new
online course that's a
collaboration with HarvardX
and GetSmarter on strategies for
online teaching and learning.
Or, not online teaching
and learning-- it's
an online course on
teaching and learning.
All right, I'll turn
it over to David now.
Can everybody hear me?
All right.
So I'm going to talk about
some of the research I do.
I'm a social psychologist.
I run the studies.
And the research I'm going
to talk about was actually
funded by HILT. So if
you think it's neat,
and you want to do something
like it, or you hate it,
and you want to do the opposite,
apply for funding from HILT.
They're great.
They fund a lot of cool projects
about education and research.
OK.
So I want to start you off
by talking about some ads you
may have seen, maybe on the
internet or on Facebook,
for this company
called MasterClass.
Their whole pitch is
that you can learn how
to do something from the best.
Pick a topic like cooking,
and you can, for a small fee,
get video instruction from
luminaries in that field.
Like here, you could
take a cooking lesson
from Wolfgang Puck,
a very famous chef.
And I just want you to imagine
a hypothetical situation
that I give you the
choice of paying that fee
to get a cooking
lesson from Wolfgang
Puck or the same cooking
lesson from this guy.
So it's not a hard question.
And I think the reason it's
not a very difficult question
to answer is that
we have an intuition
that in a lot of domains,
all else being equal,
the better someone
is at something,
the more they have to teach,
and maybe the more effective
they'll be at teaching
you how to do that thing.
And that's kind of what I
want to talk about today.
What are the limits
of that intuition?
When is it wrong?
And what are the consequences?
So a roadmap of some
of the things I'm going
to try to convince you of--
we often think that top
performers in a domain
are going to be the best
instructors in that domain.
But that's often not true.
And maybe part of the reason
we think that, even though it's
not often true, is that
top performers do teach
in a way that just sounds
very different from how
other people tend
to give instruction.
And again, I'm a
social psychologist,
so the way I do this is,
I take a lot of people
and I put them in
a situation and see
what decisions they make.
So we tried to make a situation
in which we could examine
how people teach and
learn, and how that
relates to their performance.
So what type of teaching
did I want to study?
There's a lot of different
types of teaching.
Because it's easy to implement
in this research design,
I wanted to look at the
type of teaching that
answers the question, how do I
get better at something, right?
So think of a tutor.
Think of a coach.
Think of peer instruction
in the classroom.
You're asking the
person next to you
how to do better
on a problem set.
It's teaching that's
aimed to get you
more proficient at something.
And you can think of it as
just teaching that hopefully,
if it works well, leads to
improvements in performance
of whatever task you're doing.
So the way we would study that
is pretty straightforward.
We would take a bunch of people.
We would get their baseline
performance in whatever task
we're interested in.
Then we would give
them advice, which
is just what I'm calling
the type of instructions
we're giving them,
and the teaching
they get about the task.
And then we measure
how they do again later
after that instruction.
So we're going to see
if the teaching they got
helped them do
better at the task.
Pretty straightforward, right?
We used a bunch of
different types of tasks
we were studying this stuff.
I'm just going to talk
about one, which is Boggle.
If you don't know about
Boggle, it's a great game.
You have a grid of letters, and
you have to find as many words
as you can in the grid in
a short amount of time.
So in this grid, here
is the word "ride."
Here's "kite."
Here's the word "sour."
And you usually
have a time limit.
So we might give people 60
seconds to find as many words
as they can.
And the first thing
we wanted to do
is basically interrogate that
intuition they started with,
which is saying that,
oh, people think
the better you are at
something, the better you'll
do at teaching that.
Maybe people don't think that's
true, at least with this task.
We wanted to double check.
So what we did is, I took 800
people in an online survey,
and I had them play
Boggle, just to get
a sense of what the game
was like in case they
hadn't played before.
And then they
answered a question
about who they'd want to
be taught by in the game.
So we asked a bunch
of different ways,
but one version of the
question basically said,
if you could pick
someone to teach you
how to play this game
ranging from the very
worst player to the very best
player, who would you pick?
On this graph, the
x-axis is the percentile
of performance people
chose, and the y-axis
is how often they chose it.
And you can see, the
overwhelming preference
is, people want to be taught
by the very best player they
have access to.
Another way of
asking the question,
you can split
performance into kind
of deciles, so the top 10%
of players, the bottom 10%,
all the ones in the middle.
And just ask, if
you were going to be
taught by someone
who was this good,
how helpful would that be?
And you see this pretty
strong linear relationship.
The better people
are at the game,
the better other people
predict that they're
going to teach us how to play.
So was that true, at
least for this game?
So what we did was, we
got a bunch of teachers.
We got 78 new people
online to play
this game a bunch of times.
And then they wrote
advice about this game.
Basically, they wrote
a little lesson.
Here's something
I'm going to write
for someone that's
going to help them learn
how to be better at the game.
And then we took
1,500 new people
and gave them that advice.
Each student got advice
from one teacher.
And then we had 600
people as a control
who didn't get any advice.
Because we just
wanted to make sure
that this is the kind of
game where being taught
helps at all.
If it doesn't, then
we're not going
to be able to learn
anything from our study.
From the perspective
of the students,
here's what the
study looked like.
So you'd play the game once.
That's your baseline
performance,
before you get taught.
Then you get some advice.
That's the teaching.
And then you play
a bunch more times.
And the way we measured
your improvement
is, we would just
average together
all of the times you played
after you were taught,
and then subtract from that
your baseline performance.
So that difference
is us measuring,
did the teaching have any
impact on how well you
did at the game?
In other words, was
the teaching effective?
I won't really go
through this, but people
gave really diverse types
of advice about the game--
think small, all the
words are worth one point,
don't focus on long
words, use plurals, look
at the whole puzzle,
don't go letter by letter.
There were a lot of different
strategies people used.
It was really diverse
types of strategies people
used to teach.
It wasn't the type
of task where there
was just one secret to
success, which is, I think,
how real learning works, right?
There's not just one
way to do a lesson plan.
OK.
So first, I'm not really
going to go through this.
But we did double
check that, yes,
getting taught in this game was
better than not getting taught.
So the blue bar, people who got
taught how to play the game,
did better than
people who didn't.
So this was the type of task
where being taught helped,
which is good.
Then this next graph
I'm going to show you
is the important one.
So the x-axis here
is, how skilled
your teacher was at the game.
And the y-axis is, how much
better you did at the game
after you were taught.
And it's kind of hard to parse
out this big scatter plot,
but I'll draw a
helpful line for it.
And what you see is basically
that, at least in this game,
there was no relationship
between how skilled
your teacher was at
playing this game
and how helpful their
teaching was for you to learn
how to play the game better.
In other words, if
you were a student,
and you were trying
to pick an instructor
to help you play
this game, you would
have been as well
off, on average,
picking the very worst
player to teach you
as the very best player.
It wouldn't have made a
difference in your performance.
And so it's not just about
the actual relationship
between performance and
teaching in this case.
People also predicted that
it would turn out this way.
So the teachers when you asked
them-- the red line here--
how helpful is your
teaching going to be?
The better the teachers
were on the x-axis
at playing this game,
the more helpful
they thought that their
advice was going to be,
the better teachers they
thought they would be.
They were more confident.
And same thing
with the students.
After they got their
lesson, we asked them, hey,
how much was it helpful to
get that advice that you
got from one of the previous
players in the game?
And what you see
is, whether they
were answering the question,
how helpful was the teacher,
or how much did I
improve, the more
skilled that their teacher was,
the more that these students
felt like they improved.
Even though, again,
the graph I showed
you earlier showed there
wasn't actually a relationship.
So both the teachers
and the students
thought that better performers
were doing better teaching
here, even though that
didn't seem to be the case.
So, at least in this task,
actual advice efficacy,
teaching performance,
wasn't correlated
with performance in this game.
But both the teachers and
the students thought it was.
So I don't really have a
lot of time to go into this,
but our initial
investigation seemed
to suggest that the biggest
difference we can find
between the way that
the top performers teach
and the bottom performers
in this game teach,
the difference
between their advice,
is that better performers
just give a lot more of it.
So somebody who's
very bad at this game
might give you like two
tips on how to do better,
and someone who's great
might give you 10.
And people read the 10 tips and
go, wow, this is so helpful.
But they don't do any
better than the people
who just got two.
OK.
I already went through
these takeaways.
Some consequences of
what I just told you,
at least, what I think.
So one suggestion, if this
extends to actual classroom
stuff, is that we
might sometimes
be overvaluing top-performers
as teachers, right?
A lot of times I think
that the heuristic
that students and people
making hiring decisions
use to choose teachers
is, is this person really
good at the thing
they're teaching?
And this suggests, not
that they're bad at it--
I think, if anything, our
society has way too much
devaluing of experts
these days in general--
but that we might be
undervaluing the teaching
ability of people who aren't
at the very pinnacle of doing
the thing that they're teaching.
And that is partly a problem
because we don't always
have efficient matching
between students and teachers.
Good teachers are in
short supply, high demand.
So if there's this wellspring
of great instructors
who are being overlooked
because they don't have the best
grades or the best scorers or
the best track record of doing
the thing they're teaching,
we should take another look
at that.
And I think it's
important to remember
that, just like playing Boggle
is a skill, being a surgeon
is a skill, being an athlete is
a skill, teaching is a skill.
And it would be kind of
ridiculous to expect somebody
who's a world-class
tennis player
to also be a classical pianist.
And in the same
way, why should you
expect that the very
best teachers that
are out there waiting
for you to find them also
have to be the
very best at doing
the things they're teaching?
I'll just zoom
out for one second
and say that I think of this
as one example of a broader
phenomenon in psychology
research called
"the curse of knowledge,"
which is just about
how, when you know something,
it's difficult to put yourself
in the perspective of people
who don't know that thing.
One example that people
use in studies a lot
is, if I tap a song
on the table that I'm
thinking of in my head, I
know exactly what the song is,
and it seems obvious to
me, but you might have
no idea what that song was.
That was "The Star
Spangled Banner."
And thinking of ways to
implement this principle
in the classroom, a professor in
the psychology department I've
taught with, Fiery Cushman,
has a great technique
he's used called a
mirroring exercise.
Some of you may have heard of
it, where basically, students
take samples of
their own writing,
like if they're working
on a draft of an essay,
and they just read it
aloud to a partner.
And their partner, all they
can do is just regurgitate back
exactly what they've
heard, and summarize it--
this is what you've
just read to me.
And you'd be amazed at how
much these students think,
the ideas are so crystal
clear in my head,
and as soon as they have to
just read them on the page
to someone else,
they realize how far
they have to go to bridge
the gap between their mind
and other students' minds.
So hopefully you can think
about how that principle applies
to your own teaching,
and how you think
about teaching in general.
And thank you very much.
All right, a couple of
questions for David.
Yes.
My intuition is that, as
much as this makes sense,
I wonder how it applies in
the teaching and learning
space of how we teach teachers.
Because my intuition is that
people are bad at teaching--
well, that you have
to be good at teaching
people how to teach.
Do you have
intuitions about that?
So my intuition, again,
matches exactly what everybody
predicted in the study, and
what you're articulating,
which is that,
yes, somebody who--
unless somebody is a rock
star in the classroom,
and either has a
ton of experience
or a natural ability to
engage their students
and get the most
out of them, how
can they teach me how to
improve my own teaching?
And yet, I will say
that I was involved
in pedagogy instruction in
the psychology department,
and oftentimes what
that is, is it's
a bunch of graduate students
giving each other feedback
and workshopping
their own teaching.
They're often teachers
for the first time.
We also have faculty
come in who are teachers
with years of experience, some
of them very popular, some
of them less popular, giving
feedback and suggestions.
And a lot of the most
valuable feedback I would see
didn't come from the
people I would consider
the best teachers there were.
So it's certainly-- I don't want
your takeaway from this to be
that good teachers don't--
or people who are good at
doing things, whether that's
teaching or something else,
don't teach that thing well,
but that the other people
might surprise you.
So we should solicit
feedback, for example,
about teaching, not just
from the rock-star teachers,
but from everybody else, too.
And just as a suggestion,
maybe one reason
is that people who have,
for example, been really
successful teachers
their whole life
might not be as familiar
with some of the challenges
and struggles you can
have in a classroom
if you're less
confident teacher.
Whereas someone who's had a lot
of trouble, they can be like,
you know, I also
froze up when I had
to speak in front of
people, or I never quite
knew how to manage
that discussion.
They're tapping into
different realms of knowledge.
And maybe that's part of
why they can sometimes
be more effective
than we expect,
at least that's
what this suggests.
So I'm interested in
this notion that you
can't expect a top tennis player
to also be a concert pianist.
And so one might then apply that
to an R1 research institution,
saying that we might have
research faculty and teaching
faculty, which is a somewhat
controversial idea around here.
What are your thoughts on--
do you think that's
a leap too far,
or are you nudging
in that direction?
I think that it depends
on what your goals are.
So if your goals are to have a
curriculum and program in which
you're giving the students
the best possible experience,
then that would argue
strongly in favor
of what you're
suggesting, at least
that's where my research
leads me to conclude.
And that you want to--
you can't have it both ways,
and try to slice the pie
and find the people who are
the top, top researchers
and the top, top teachers
without sacrificing something
in both directions.
There just aren't
enough people out there
who are amazing at both.
And you're kind
of leaving people
by the wayside who are good
at one but not the other.
That being said, it seems like
the students and the teachers
all were very happy
with their experience
when they were taught
by the great professors
in our studies.
So unless you're in
a situation, I think,
where you can really clearly
measure the learning outcomes
and then compare that to how
it would be if you changed up
the teaching staff, I think
it's hard to make the argument
for a dramatic change.
It's just hard to measure these
things in a higher education
setting.
But yeah, I think,
even short of that,
I think any ways to
bring more and focus more
on great teaching in an
R1 institution can only
be for the better.
All right.
One more question, and
then we'll move on.
I have a question.
So if I'm a Boggle player
in the second-best Boggle,
might it be, does
your research show,
am I going to learn
better from somebody
that might be in the fourth,
versus somebody that's
in the ninth or tenth?
I was sure that this--
so just if people
didn't follow that, I
was sure that this would
be the case, that it wouldn't
just be the case that you
as a student would learn
well from somebody who
was at the very
bottom of performance
compared to the very top,
compared to the middle.
I was sure that what
would really be going on
is that the best thing,
the optimal thing,
would be that you would learn
from somebody a little bit
better than you or a
little bit worse than you,
or there would be
some critical distance
of performance between you
and your teacher that would
lead to the best outcomes.
I've looked and I looked, and I
couldn't find it in this data.
Again, this is a very
abstract toy study with games.
Who knows how it
relates to outcomes
in the actual classroom.
I wouldn't be surprised
if that type of gap
comes more into play
in those situations.
But I didn't find it here.
It's a great question.
All right.
Thank you, David.
[APPLAUSE]
All right.
So we just heard two
very different kinds
of examples of ways
that you can go
about studying learning,
one looking at really trying
to figure out what is
going on in my classroom
with my students, another
looking in more of a research
study, experimental situation.
I'm going to give you
two more examples of ways
that people might think
about studying learning,
and then we'll get
into trying to ask
some of our own questions.
OK, so here's our image Again,
the one that Henrike actually
didn't want to talk about.
So this is an example of some
work done by Peter Felten, who
is a historian and director
of the Center for Teaching
and Learning at Elon University.
So he's a historian, and
he had given his students
lots of texts to
analyze, and then
he started giving his
students visual data.
And for a while, he
just assumed that they
know what to do with it and
how to make sense of it.
And then he started
questioning that.
And so to try to figure out
where his students were at,
he created some
in-class activities.
And in these
in-class activities,
he gave them a series of
images, visual images,
and had them answer
certain questions
about, what do you think is
the meaning of this image,
where did it come from,
et cetera, et cetera.
And he also asked them
questions about, if I gave you
a list of different sources
of historical information,
how would you value
these historical sources?
And based on these
types of questions,
he actually got
a lot of insights
about how his students thought
about different types of data,
and in particular how they
were interpreting visual data,
things that he didn't realize.
And based on what he
learned from these studies,
it actually changed
his teaching,
and he introduced new
types of assignments
to help his students understand
how to deal with visual data.
All right.
So another way you might go
about studying learning, what
if you have a question
about, I have created
this new online module to help
my students in my chemistry
class understand
topic A. OK, so what's
an approach you
could take for that?
You could imagine that
you give your students
a pre-test on topic A, and then
you break the students in half.
And half of the students have
access to this online module,
and half of the students
have some access
to other types of materials,
maybe reading materials,
on this topic, but
not the online module.
And then they might
have a post-test,
and you can see how
much they learned
about this topic based on
exposure to this online module.
And you might also give
them some survey questions
about their attitudes and their
experience with this module.
So this is an example where it's
more on the experimental side.
You have a control group.
You have a pre-test.
You have a post-test.
You're also assessing attitudes.
So as Henrike very
nicely described to us,
there's a lot of
different ways of thinking
about student learning.
And the first example here,
as Henrike talked about,
is, I think, in many
ways easier to implement
in your authentic
classroom setting,
of you don't have to be breaking
your students into control
groups and having them
have different educational
experiences.
In the second case,
you'd need to be
going through IRB approval to
be thinking about your students
as subjects.
So there's a lot
of different things
to be thinking about as you
want to study student learning.
Just wanted to get a
range of ideas out there.
So if you want to
think about what's
going on in your own
classroom, what you want to do
is, you want to first start
by identifying a problem
and generating a question.
And so you want to think
about a question that
is relevant and meaningful
to you, something that
is something that
you could actually
study with the students
that you work with.
And the focus of
this is something
that you actually can tackle
in a reasonable amount of time.
And I think those are types
of concerns Henrike actually
addressed very nicely.
So people who are
thinking about SOTL,
the scholarship of
teaching and learning,
have broken these
types of questions
into a number of
different categories.
And I'm going to just
raise two of them,
because I think that they're
the easiest to start with.
And one is types of
questions about what is.
So these are types
of questions that
are seeking to describe
student learning or teaching
approaches, just get
a better understanding
of where your students are at,
what's happening, and so on.
And another type of
question is, what works?
And these are types of studies
where you're seeking evidence
for the effectiveness
of a teaching strategy.
So what you're
going to do now is,
first, I want you to think
about who your audience is.
So some of you might be
thinking about students
who you teach
directly, but I also
know that some
people in this room
are academic professionals
who might be working
with faculty or with
graduate students,
and helping other folks like
that with their teaching.
And so in that
case, you might be
thinking about
students in a course
that you support, but maybe
that you don't teach directly.
Or you might be thinking
about, your audience
might actually be the faculty
of the graduate student
clients whom you work with.
So what you're going
to do is think about,
what is a question
about their learning
that you'd like to explore?
So on your table, you will
find a one-page handout.
And so you can work on
this one-page handout.
It specifically asks
the same question.
And take maybe two minutes
to write down a question,
and then take
another two minutes
to talk with a neighbor,
to share your questions
with each other.
OK So first step is
identifying a question
that you care about
about student learning.
And of course, our next
question, next step,
is that we need to think
about gathering evidence.
And there's a lot
of different forms
that evidence can come in, and
I'm going to go through a few.
First, you can think about ways
of collecting direct evidence
about student learning.
So this is asking
questions directly
about what did the
students learn.
And you might do this through
samples of student work.
You might be looking
very carefully
at particular responses to
a particular essay prompt.
You might be looking carefully
at a set of quiz questions
on a topic that you care about.
You might be looking at how the
student created concept maps.
Maybe you're looking
at student responses
to a minute paper, where they
answered questions about,
what was the most important
thing you learned today,
and what questions
do you still have?
There's all sorts of types of
formative in-class assessments
that you might analyze, all
different types of student
work.
You might be making
observations of students.
If you want to be studying group
work, you might, in addition
to doing surveys, you
might have other ways
of actually observing what
they're doing in their groups.
You might collect students'
reflections themselves
on their own values, their
attitudes, their beliefs.
There's also indirect evidence
about student learning.
So what do students report
that they've learned?
And this might be collected
through surveys or interviews,
where students are
reflecting on their learning,
or about their satisfaction
with the learning experience.
You might also
include reflections
by instructors about what
their observations are
of student learning.
And as you're gathering
different types of evidence,
you can think about both
quantitative approaches.
So for example, if
you're doing a survey,
you might have questions
with Likert scales,
where you have
numerical responses.
You might be also looking
at qualitative approaches.
So you might be doing
interviews and focus
groups, where you
might be getting
more nuanced type of data.
So this is to give you
the sense that there's
a lot of different
approaches that you
can use to collect evidence
about student learning.
I also want you to
realize that beyond--
so there are certainly going to
be cases where you are studying
student work, and this is going
to be very specific to what
is happening in your
classroom with assignments
that you've created.
But there's also a
lot of tools out there
that you can take advantage of.
You don't need to
continually be reinventing
the wheel for everything.
So there are ways,
there are a lot of tools
out there for assessing
student learning or knowledge.
A couple of examples--
there's something called
the AACU Value Rubrics,
which are some excellent tools.
They're not assessments,
per se, but they're
rubrics for that
have been created
in a lot of different
categories of competencies
that are valuable for students
to be learning in higher
education.
And then there are a lot
of concept inventories,
particularly in the sciences,
which are very well validated
instruments looking
at whether students
have learned key concepts
in different fields.
So these are things that you
can look up for your field.
And then there's a lot of
scales that are basically
sets of questions
that are going to get
at a lot of different attributes
of students-- students'
academic self-efficacy,
what is their belief
and their confidence in
their ability to succeed
in academics; students
critical thinking;
their motivation;
their metacognition,
so their ability to reflect
on their own learning.
There are scales about student
strategies for learning,
students' study
behaviors, and much more.
So those are some examples.
I put a reference that's on
the bottom of your handout
of this booklet called "The
Compendium of Scales for Use
in the Scholarship of
Teaching and Learning"
that has lots and lots of
examples and references
for scales that might be useful.
OK.
So now what I want
you to do is, you've
got an overview of
types of strategies
that you might use for
studying student learning.
And what I want you to
do is, in a small group--
and what does a
small group mean?
I'm going to let you choose
whether at your table
it's best to working in
a group of two or three.
You can divide
yourselves as you wish.
So maybe groups of two,
maybe groups of three,
if you're at a table of
four, that's also OK.
So you were just starting
to share your questions.
Choose one of your
questions to focus on
for the rest of this activity.
And once you've
chosen that question,
start brainstorming
some approaches
that you could take to go
about answering that question.
So we're going to take about
seven minutes to do this.
So in a small group,
pick a question,
and brainstorm some strategies
to answer that question.
Has everyone figured it out?
You've got some approaches?
OK.
So what we're
going to do now is,
I'd love to hear
from some of you.
Share with each other what
you've been thinking about.
So what question are
you interested in,
and what were some
approaches you took?
So on the bottom
of your handout,
there are links to a couple of
great websites with information
about scholarship of
teaching and learning.
Also, before you
walk out, there's
a stapled handout
for each of you.
These are pages that a group at
Vanderbilt University's Center
for Teaching put together
about scholarship
of teaching and learning, and
a lot of great information
about how to start
thinking about a problem
and how to go about
collecting evidence.
All right.
Thank you very much.
Lunch is downstairs.
[APPLAUSE]